[Music]
hardly any other name in Hollywood
history is as well known as the one of
Walt Disney for 100 years the company
has Enchanted innumerable hearts of all
ages with its imaginative stories but on
the occasion of its big anniversary the
company seems to be facing a crisis the
costs are exploding numerous movies and
series are falling short of expectations
and one storm follows the next many
people are asking themselves what is
going on with
Disney
the last few years have been beyond
messy for the giant Corporation let's
jump back to 2019 for a moment things
were still going quite well for the
company CEO Bob Iger had been in charge
for 14 years under his leadership Disney
acquired huge Brands such as Pixar
Marvel Studios lucasfilm and 21st
Century Fox Iger entered the streaming
Market in a big way and Disney plus was
initially a great success with low
subscription costs and a wide range of
Disney Classics however things went
downhill from here Bob Iger stepped down
as CEO and appointed his longtime
business partner Bob Chek as the new CEO
of Disney a decision that he would later
describe as the biggest mistake of his
career unlike Iger Chek does not have a
knack for the world of film whereas his
predecessor is a showman who can somehow
get along with anyone chapek is a
typical businessman who is more
interested in figures rather than people
over the next 3 years he basically fell
out with all the big names in the
industry and disregarded many of his
colleagues advice however he also had to
deal with difficult circumstances not
only did he have to lead Disney through
the times of the pandemic but his former
boss Bob Iger who still has a lot to say
at Disney is also continually sabotaging
him behind the scenes and badmouthing
his every decision in front of others
this was followed by a number of smaller
and larger scandals actress Scarlett
Johansson for example sued her employer
Disney for releasing her film Black
Widow simultaneously in cinemas as well
as on Disney Plus in violation of all
agreements Chek then issued a statement
accusing the actress of being greedy and
selfish in times of the pandemic a move
that many
resented Chek first invested a lot of
money in content production in order to
increase Disney Plus subscription
figures the costs kept Rising according
to many critics however the quality also
declined this is because more money does
not automatically mean more creative
resources the existing amount of
filmmakers was severely overworked
resulting in impossible deadlines a lack
of quality control and difficult working
condition itions behind the scenes this
led to an uprising among the effects
artists at Marvel who founded their
first Union moreover viewers were
increasingly dissatisfied with the
movies and series that were created
under these conditions many experts
agree that the Pixar Star Wars and
Marvel franchises have been damaged as a
result unsurprisingly Bob Iger shares
this criticism and recently announced
that he had always believed that
quantity could damage quality this is
precisely what has happened and what has
caused Disney to lose its focus
but has this Approach at least paid off
for Disney's streaming services the aim
was to reach at least 215 million
subscribers for Disney plus by the end
of 2023 in fact it only managed to reach
150 million that's even 14 million
subscribers less than a year earlier
incidentally over the course of a year
the difference between expectations and
reality results in around7 billion less
Revenue than hoped for in the past 4
years Disney's streaming service has
made losses of more than $10 billion in
indeed Disney is facing financial
difficulties the overall success of
streaming services which the company
itself has helped to boost has also
accelerated the demise of linear
Television Once a huge source of income
for the company which also owns TV
channel ABC and Sports Network ESPN
Disney's Share value has fallen by half
in the last 3 years on top of this a
number of movies have flopped recently
The Little Mermaid Indiana Jones 5 and
Haunted Mansion all fell short of
expectations in 2023 even Disney's
beloved Studio Pixar initially struggled
to make an impact with elemental which
only became a success as time went on
the Marvels was the weakest opening ever
for a Marvel film and the animated film
wish also failed to make a strong
impression in December it is important
to mention that it is by no means true
that there's a lack of movie goers
Disney movies are still enjoyed by many
people however the Productions are
significantly more expensive than they
used to be both The Little Mermaid and
Indie cost around $300 million to
produce in addition to marketing which
easily doubles the budget in theaters
they grossed $570 million and 380
million respectively which is actually a
decent figure just not good enough
considering the costs as head at least
cheek no longer had to experience these
flops at the end of 2022 it was decided
to call it quits and chapek was fired
his predecessor became his successor Bob
Iger returned to the company as the new
former CEO as he had supposedly always
known better anyway he was now tasked
with leading the company back to
success but how exactly does Iger intend
to achieve this his first step a harsh
austerity program over 8,000 employees
have been dismissed and Disney Plus
subscription prices have been massively
increased the company is also
considering selling the ABC TV channel
and bringing in financial partners for
the ESPN sports Empire at times there
were rumors that Apple could buy
Disney's entire TV division or that the
entire group would even be sold off
which seems an unlikely radical step
nevertheless such massive changes are
not entirely impossible for example the
big movie Distributors Warner Brothers
and Paramount are currently looking into
merging to create a new gigantic
Corporation an action that would put
further pressure on competitor Disney in
terms of production Bob Iger is also
pursuing a new approach making fewer
films and focusing on high quality
instead in the coming business year
Disney aims to spend $25 billion on its
Productions that is $2 billion less than
the year before Disney's financial
situation gradually began to improve in
the last quarter according to CNBC the
streaming services only made a loss of
$387 million compared to almost 1.5
billion a year
earlier pandemic internal disputes
working conditions the audience probably
couldn't care less about all these
problems as long as Disney continues to
produce great movies and series however
both the box office results and the
comments columns convey the impression
that Disney can no longer win over
audiences the way they used to but why
is is that let's take a look together at
the big movies of recent years and what
has
changed reproach number one Disney is
only producing remakes and sequels there
are hardly any Original Stories these
days is the number of remakes really as
high as it seems Let's ignore the Star
Wars and MCU franchise universes for the
moment and focus on the movies from the
classic Disney Studios since 2010 almost
30 movies have been made for the big
screen including 19 remakes or sequels
in comparison in the same period from 19
1997 to 2009 there were only two sequels
among almost 20 films by Disney please
note that we are only talking about
Cinema releases here Disney has been
producing sequels and prequels to its
well-known films since the 9s be it
Peter Pan the mermaid or The Lion King
between 1997 in 2010 there were over 28
more movies however these small
Productions did not receive as much
public attention as their theatrical
counterparts and were also produced
significantly cheaper things are
different these days regardless of
whether it's a iCal release or a first
release on Disney plus we come across
continuations of older stories
everywhere whether we like it or not a
vast range of content that is
expensively promoted and accordingly
hotly debated especially when viewers
are
dissatisfied reproach number two Disney
is too woke political messages are more
of a priority to them than credible
stories this is certainly one of the
biggest criticisms of modern Disney
movies the main issue here is the way in
which characters are written and cast
let's take the little mermaid as an
example in the 1989 animated film she's
portrayed as having white skin and red
hair in the 2023 liveaction remake she
is played by the African-American hi
Bailey the issues Focus primarily on
three points on the one hand it's about
supposed realism mermaids couldn't be
black it wouldn't make sense for her
father to be played by the light-skinned
Spaniard Javier bardam and so on and so
forth of course depending on the movie
you can argue about how important such
points are in fictional fantasy stories
however it obviously disrup the story
for many viewers when familiar settings
are changed especially if they're based
on historical Origins such as European
stories in the case of Ariel on the
other hand the portrayal challenges what
viewers know from the old films why does
Ariel suddenly have a different skin
color many perceive this striking change
which has no justification within the
story as a political influence from the
outside beloved characters are
superficially changed to allow for a
diverse cast it's not just about
changing White characters as there would
be just as much outrage if Mulan were to
suddenly be played by White actress for
example fun fact there were similar
discussions about the first animated
film when Disney gave the mermaid bright
red hair at the time this was also a
deviation from the original fairy tale
but without the internet the storm
was of course considerably smaller many
people wonder when it comes to telling
modern stories with a diverse cast why
not tell new stories instead of changing
the popular old ones although this is no
guarantee of success see flops such as
wish or strange world it is obviously
not an obst in view of great hits such
as Encanto in its long history Disney
has covered every possible cultural
sphere and has repeatedly enjoyed
success both with European settings such
as Beauty and the Beast or Frozen and
with stories like Mulan or Moana so it
is not at all the case that audiences
automatically Reject movies that are not
wi enough anyone who assumes that every
critic is racist is therefore making
things too easy for
themselves Disney seems to be torn
between two goals on one side they
stoping to take a low risk by revisiting
old hits the idea behind this is that
those who already know the predecessor
are more likely to go to the movies to
watch the Remake as well and remakes in
particular appeal to both nostalgic
adults and their children new technical
possibilities offer the ideal
justification for the company to present
the old stories in a fresh new look at
the same time though they also want to
adapt to current social trends and
expectations the problem with this is
that if for example films used to use
lots of cliches that are now outdated
how can you tell the same kind of
stories without simply replicating these
portrayals Disney's response so far has
been to try and change the stories
accordingly skin colors are changed and
characters are generously Rewritten but
regardless of how good bad or believable
the finished movie may be in itself the
audience has given a different movie to
what they expected the most recent
storm concerned the remake of Snow White
in which the character known to have
skinn as white as snow is played by a
Latina and the Seven Dwarves who were
even part of the fairy tale title were
to be replaced by magical beings of all
shapes and sizes these blatant changes
caused so much ridicule and outrage that
Disney at least backtracked when it came
to the dwarves the movie was postponed
and Snow White's companions were turned
back into dwarves albeit CGI
animated traditionally animated Disney
movies are aimed at the whole family
children don't really care whether there
was a white aerial 34 years ago after
all there are all kinds of characters in
all kinds of variations as movies series
or to
it rarely distracts from the enjoyment
as long as the story itself is
entertaining obviously it is of little
use to Disney if only children want to
see the movies the costs are simply too
high nowadays and the target audience
too broad think of remakes and sequels
Disney is relying on the money of
grown-ups and former Disney kids in
particular have different demands when
it comes to new films if we take a look
at Disney's modern animated films the
question arises of how neutral older
viewers can actually be you've probably
heard the saying everything was better
in the old days and how every generation
in human history has claimed this time
and time again most of us grew up with
Disney movies be it old classics or the
latest movies that everyone talked about
at school and even many years later we
still like these films probably even a
bit more partly because they have shaped
our image of what a Disney film should
be like regardless of what modern movies
do differently from their predecessors
Disney will always find it difficult to
keep up with our wishes and expectations
and repeat the magical feeling of the
past that doesn't mean that they can't
succeed in doing so from time to time
but the last few years have shown that
Disney isn't doing itself any favors by
simply trying to please everyone with
every single project Disney has of
course long since stopped limiting
itself to the production of family films
for example just a few years ago no one
would have guessed that the brutal
Predator film prey would be released
exclusively on Disney plus such
Productions show that good and
successful movies for adults are also
possible Under the Disney label and at a
fraction of the cost of Blockbusters
perhaps this is also the actual ual goal
that Disney should be pursuing a
diversity of movies instead of diversity
in every
movie despite all the accusations of
political motivation Disney as a global
Mega Corporation is focused on one thing
above all else they want to make money
critics love the popular phrase go woke
go broke a mocking reference to the fact
that efforts to promote more diversity
and certain messages result in financial
damage this applies to typical Disney
animated films as well as Star Wars the
MCU and the like so did Disney simply
back the wrong horse did they perhaps
want to increase their viewership but
lost their core audience in the process
it's hard to figure that out as there
are simply too many factors that
influence whether a movie is a success
or not not to mention that everyone
understands the word woke differently
anyway but no matter which of the
aformentioned points of criticism you
apply if it were so clear that this
seemingly new type of film is not
worthwhile for Disney shouldn't this be
clearly reflected in the revenues what
is clear is that 17 of the 20 most
successful Disney movies of all time in
terms of box office takings were
released in 2010 or later inflation
adjusted incidentally among these movies
Frozen is the only one that is not a
sequel or part of a franchise but the
truth is that apart from Avatar 2 not a
single one of these movies was released
after 2019 the launch year of Disney
plus and the Takeover of CEO Bob Chek so
even if the allegations against Disney
have been around for many years at least
at the box office things have only been
doing so poorly for a relatively short
time but what's the matter now with
Disney what should they do differently
so that they can make successful
releases and the public will like them
again we wish there were simple answers
irrespective of whether it's an original
story a sequel or a remake whether it's
a particularly diverse production or an
old-fashioned adaptation there are
examples of successful movies and flops
of all kinds perhaps the answer
ultimately lies Less in superficial
factors of what category a movie can be
put into but rather whether talented
people have the opportunity to tell a
beautiful story and that without the
extreme pressure of recent years to
produce as much content as possible in
the shortest possible time if current
CEO Bob Iger is to be believed this is
the way forward let's hope so for Disney
and for all of us what are your thoughts
on the developments at Disney do you
also think the movies and series have
lost its quality or do you perhaps
appreciate some of the changes we look
forward to reading your
[Music]
comments
he